o que a gente quer um pouco discutir
aqui saindo do campo da crítica sair do
campo do puritanismo é algo um pouco
mais provocativo
na hora que a gente tem as conexões
desenvolvimento conhecimento e cultura
ea gente pensa naturalmente por uma
conexão linear conhecimento ligado à
universidade cultura ligada drumond e o
desenvolvimento ligado à mineração são
obesidade que nos vem claro
só que as conexões muitas vezes elas não
podem ser estabelecidas dessa forma pelo
pecado de nós sermos simplista demais e
acaba nos deixando de lado toda
oportunidade que a gente tem ao nosso
redor
a ideia que a gente tem hoje para
discutir conexões
é algo muito mais endêmico algo nosso
algo que a gente constrói até no nosso
próprio organismo
nós somos um exemplo vivo de como as
conexões são importantes
o nosso organismo só funciona porque a
gente tem milhões de conexões
acontecendo simultaneamente e essa
expressão conexão
ela está muito ligada à percepção de
participação de troca algo que chega a
um consenso
dificilmente a gente pode imaginar uma
conexão onde uma parte tem que ceder
totalmente para se conectar na outra e
isso é uma coisa muito importante pra
gente ter que tavira
então é um desenho um pouco confuso para
que nos inspire 3 provocações
eu acho que a primeira provocação que a
gente pode fazer nesse campo é assim
esse conhecimento gerado na academia
ele está assaltando os muros
naturalmente a gente liga conhecimento
da academia com universidades
pessoalmente mas esse conhecimento que é
produzido hoje que a gente tem ensino
pesquisa extensão e aí a gente pode
faltar um pouco mais a unifei
eu acho que a gente pode chegar uma
questão regional incluindo o foco a
funcesi os pólos 100 presenciais da
cidade
esse conhecimento realmente está
faltando os muros está conseguindo
chegar na comunidade está conseguindo
fazer uma diferença na comunidade e é
claro que aí tem um papel
importantíssimo da extensão
fundamental a forma disso chegado a
alcançar de ser transformador é o
conhecimento saltar os muros porque se o
conhecimento fica lá dentro da
universidade nas prateleiras
ele não vai ter utilidade e por isso que
eu disse que de forma alguma a gente
está tendo uma crítica a determinadas
questões
mas é uma reflexão e é uma resposta que
a gente vai ter provocativo mas o que
ela não pode ser um sim ou não eu acho
que a gente vê bons exemplos e vamos ver
aqui bons exemplos de coisas que já
acontecem que salta esses muros mas o
papel transformador que a gente precisa
em itabira da academia é muito maior
é aquilo que o renato bem falou é algo
transformador de uma economia ea gente
sabe muito que não adianta só a questão
econômica dando bem desenvolvida se a
gente não tiver esse lastro da
participação ambiental social e
econômica que é chamado triple bottom
line
a gente está perdendo espaço a gente
está deixando de fazer excelência
a gente está preocupando só com uma
conta a segunda provocação
será que essa cultura gerada por drumond
ela é percebida como ativo do morumbi
indo é um ativo e é muito importante a
gente perceber isso é um ativo econômico
social ambiental cultural riqueza ele
sim a riqueza mas será que isso é
percebido como riqueza ou será que
infelizmente a gente ainda não consegue
alcançar o potencial risco é muito fácil
a gente vê uma riqueza como uma reserva
mineral
ela tem ali o número x de toneladas
então você tem uma dimensão daquilo
agora drumond infinito do mundo é algo
que pode muito bem transformar em
itabira por que ele inspira não é usar
drumond e se inspirarem do mundo para
que a gente consiga entender um
combativo transformar essa cidade ea
última provocação
esse desenvolvimento que a mineração
gerou nos últimos 100 120 anos somos a
cidade mineradora quase desde a origem
ele conseguiu se transformar em
prosperidade e vamos mais uma vez vamos
esquecer
aquele discurso antigo de cavalli tem
obrigação para com isso é a mineração
atividade
a gente ainda infelizmente encara o
minério de ferro em itabira como riqueza
mineiro não é riqueza minério recurso
infinito
então nós temos que ser muito mais
conscientes dessa discussão
a receita que os recursos gera ele
conseguiu transformar em itabira no
território próspero
essas respostas evidentemente ela não
tem um senhor não como finitude
elas são provocações para que a gente
possa pensar assim porque é muito
importante que na hora que a gente
queria fazer conexões a gente amplie
nosso horizonte sobre cada situação
dessa
essas três respostas ou três conjuntos
de resposta que a gente pode realmente
embaralha a cabeça da gente nós temos
hoje em itabira é realidade
absolutamente discrepantes
um dado que a gente apresenta e assusta
47% da população com mais de 25 anos têm
o fundamental incompleto é analfabeta
47% da população com mais de 25 anos em
itabira é fundamental completo ou
analfabeto sem essa realidade não nos
incomodar não nos provocar essa reflexão
sobre tudo isso que a gente está falando
a gente vai estabelecer conexões que
isso se junte em estratégias para esse
desenvolvimento futuro nós estamos
perdendo histórico e eu acho que cabia a
capacidade se uma referência mundial em
sustentabilidade
o conceito sustentabilidade que a gente
apresenta é usar os recursos de forma
razoável para que as futuras gerações
tenham acesso a essas mesmas benesses
itabira nós estamos construindo hoje as
perguntas elas não são direcionadas para
uma pessoa ou duas é para nós
nós é que temos a incumbência de
encontrar essas respostas
e hoje essas conexões para que a gente
tem essas respostas bem construídas
a gente não pode pensar em conexões
óbvias nessas ligações que geram zona de
conforto pra gente é muito comum a gente
só ligar o conhecimento como obrigação
da academia o desenvolvimento como
obrigação da mineração ea cultura ligada
drumond e pronto a cultura fica na sua
caixinha o desenvolvimento econômico na
sua casa
e apoio o conhecimento na caixinha da
universidade
essas conexões elas não se podem mais
ser pensadas no século 21
isso é uma ótima notícia mesmo que a
gente tenha um passado muito dedicado a
esse tipo de incoerência ou coerência a
gente tem que olhar pra frente a gente
brinca que o retrovisor é menor que o
parabrisa exatamente pra isso a gente
fala menos para trás mais pra frente e é
isso que a gente busca as conexões no
século 21 elas são muito mais
estabelecidas dessa forma esses lágrima
tanto pra ler não é uma provocação mesmo
as conexões elas estão juntas elas são
misturadas
não há mais uma separação isso e para
aquilo e pronto
drumond e cultura acabou não
não podemos pensar dessa forma se a
gente continuar entendendo minério como
riqueza que gera abundância a gente fica
na zona de conforto é recurso acaba
drumond ativo é do moto em condição de
inspirar o desenvolvimento ea nova
economia tem nós somos atores como fazer
isso
essa é a diferença fundamental para que
a gente se convença da nossa importância
nós vamos fazer a diferença ea gente não
pode ser um fã nista realmente a
situação e desafiadora mas ela não é
ruim
ela não é péssima e ela depende de nós
para ser mudada
qual de nós lá no íntimo não quer
realmente uma cidade próspera uma cidade
com mais igualdade social
uma cidade que o índice de gini itabira
o índice gini que mede a desigualdade
social vai de 0 a 1 quanto mais perto de
zero menor de itabira 0 51 será que a
gente quer uma cidade que tem tanta
geração de riqueza por meio de um
recurso finito
a gente quer isso para a cidade a gente
quer realmente uma postura
transformadora de cada um de nós e aí
mais uma vez drumond é muito inspirador
do mundo é alguém imaginou essa cidade
vivendo essa realidade essa realidade
que nós vivemos o que domou praticava
não era a mineração tem inércia é o
nosso entregar se a este tipo de
situação pacífico
inerte às transformações que a gente
precisa em itabira são transformações
que nós vamos fazer não dá pra culpar o
próximo vizinho o prefeito a autoridade
o governador o papa o risco não há
transformação acontece pela vontade da
sociedade e é isso que a gente tem
construído é isso que a gente vê que é
possível fazer
nascida a gente tem um bom exemplo de
como isso acontece quando a gente
entender que as conexões do século 21
são feitas dessa forma multifacetada as
multi conectadas
a gente entende que a oportunidade ainda
está para ser construído e é bacana
pensar
o século 21 é só uma adolescente que
completa a maioridade ano que vem talvez
um pouco mais novo que a maioria de
vocês estudantes da unifei olha que
bacana oportunidade nós temos não só
vocês nós mais velhos porque as conexões
diferentes no século 21 exige um novo
pensar nosso dessa geração de ataque
estabelecida com 30 40 50 80 anos a
gente transformar o território nós temos
que ter essa energia e vigor
a idéia de se inspirar em promon e não
foi tomada uma coincidência maravilhosos
mousinho recitar o poema eu sabia antes
mas eu tinha colocado os poemas que nos
provoca muito esse poema foi escrito em
1926 publicado no primeiro livro tomou
neste poema do monarca muito as conexões
ele coloca claramente cada um de nós tem
um pedaço no pico do cauê esse pedaço é
o pedaço do recurso que ele tem que ser
colocado e não é o recurso mineral só é
o recurso que a cidade oferece essa
dimensão a gente não pode ficar
lastimando que qual está a ir embora e
chorando não é isso que vai mudar a
realidade ea nossa ação os homens vão de
cabeça baixa
as crianças vão para a escola
os ingleses contra a mina ea última
frase só
a porta da venda do carro cujo cisma com
a derrota em comparar só só ele mas tem
hora que o do tucano há muitos somos
todos nós uns desses vamos ainda que
itabira é uma cidade derrotada
que bom é a cidade vizinha bonn e tal
lugar melhor é aquele que a gente não
entende que o que do montado nos
provocando é que nós temos que fazer
essa cidade melhor
cada um de nós do morro ele foi muito
incompreendido
quem é um pouco mais velho em cadeira
sabe até hoje um pouco mais mas
especialmente na década de 70 e 80
ele era uma palavra proibida na cidade
porque achava que ele não gostava de
saber será será com a pessoa comum que
escreveu tantos e tantos livros sobre
gabeira escreveu tantos poemas escreveu
tantas crônicas falou e amor essa cidade
tanto realmente não gostava
será mesmo que a gente pode acreditar
nesse condená-lo ostracismo entender que
ele é uma geração de inspiração
permanente para que a gente tenha o
desenvolvimento social econômico
cultural ambiental
essa ideia é muito falsa mas ela ainda
permeia eu lembro que eu ouvi muito que
eu não gostava de dormir ou as pessoas
não gostavam que ela não gosta de humor
que nunca fez nada por cadeira é ruim
ouvir isso é pior ainda entender que a
gente
ao fazer essa pergunta a gente está
acreditando sempre ao outro e não a nós
mesmos a responsabilidade o que a gente
respondia quando era criança
uma ligação bacana familiar é que não
importa muito perguntar o que dilma fez
não importa saber o que eu estou fazendo
é muito mais rico do que a gente pode
fazer é acreditar realmente que a
diversificação econômica é absolutamente
premente
não há outra forma de pensar na cidade
no futuro porque é um causo
sustentabilidade no futuro se a gente
não tivesse conceito praticado que o
território minerador que se transforma
por meio do conhecimento em um
território de tecnologia
tecnologia para o agronegócio tecnologia
para cultura tecnologia para a indústria
criativa tecnologia para o
desenvolvimento das empresas de
tecnologia para que a gente tem um
território mais competitivo e não é só
itabira
a gente não pode pensar o
desenvolvimento da fronteira física
acabou e tabira começou levado a cabo
desenvolvimento da capacidade nossa nos
unir a todos os municípios da região já
é um pato desenvolvimento regional e é
isso que a gente quer aproveitar esse
século 21 ainda adolescente para ter a
mesma energia que o adolescente tem
mesmo que a gente tenha 50 70 80
não existe uma resposta para cada
provocação daquela existe na verdade um
conjunto de respostas que a gente tenha
que sair da nossa zona de conforto é o
mais importante a gente consegue a
diversificação econômica se a gente
fosse comparar o futebol é um jogo de
futebol
nós já passamos os 90 minutos nós já
passamos o primeiro tempo da prorrogação
estamos no segundo no final do segundo
tempo da prorrogação
daqui a pouco vai ter disputa por
pênaltis a gente não pode deixar essa
disputa por pênaltis fazer com que
tavira percam trem da história e não
consiga diversificar sua economia
a responsabilidade nossa é fazer isso
acontecer pela cultura pela indústria
criativa pelo agronegócio e pelo
fortalecimento da economia local
especialmente pela tecnologia que
permeia todos esses setores de
tecnologia que a gente vê que hoje a
tecnologia social tecnologia ambiental
tecnologia econômica tecnologia como um
motor para isso acontecer aí aquelas
três provocações vão ser respondidas
paulatinamente
que bom que a gente tenha bons
argumentos em exposição para responder a
essas provocações que as respostas são
íntimas é nós fazermos e há uma vontade
grande para nós fazemos não é o
fanatismo não enxergar uma realidade
dourada
ao contrário é distribuir fechada porque
terreno para a capinagem obrigado pela
atenção parabéns a vocês
[Aplausos]